thank you
welcome all of you to this press
conference Russia's on provoked invasion
of Ukraine
has brought War to Europe and in this
war Putin is using energy as a weapon
and has put Europe as we all know on the
brink of an energy crisis with Sky
rocketing Energy prices and high
inflation
it is clear for everyone that gas and
electricity prices are a serious
challenge to all Europeans
for our households
for our industry
we need to discuss this together also at
a European level and we look we need to
look at all options
um I welcome the new usola
it will look urgently into a way forward
in in all these different aspects
at the same time as all of you know we
are facing a climate crisis in the
Baltic Sea
as we stand here together today we are
the front line of European energy
security and we are sharing a huge
potential for offshore wind
I'm very honored to have the president
of the commission
and my Baltic Sea colleagues by my side
today I think we today have taken a very
important step
with the Marine Board declaration we
have agreed to build an even closer
cooperation on energy and green
transition
we need to put all necessary instruments
to use to free us from Putin's Gas and
energy
but as long as we depend on fossil fuels
we will be at a risk all of us so we
have to speed up the green transition we
have agreed to increase offshore wind in
the Baltic Sea Sevenfold
by 2030 that is more than the current
wind offshore capacity in the whole of
EU today
we have to integrate our Energy Systems
closer together and step up also the
political cooperation and that is why I
have invited all of you today
so uh first of all thank you all of you
for participating today and I am very
happy that we have been able to to
um that we have taken so ambitious
decisions where it is extremely
important for the climate crisis and
because of the war in in Ukraine
uh that was the few remarks from from uh
starting point so I will pass the floor
now to to Ukiah welcome
yes thank you thank you Mata for
organizing this very timely event as you
said
um Danish energy reforms are also a very
good example for all of us and and role
model for a long time and
um I'm very glad to be here today with
my colleagues to seek solutions to
enhance and boost transition to
renewable energy resources and cut
ourselves from Russian energy because
they are using this as a weapon after
rounds of interesting discussions we
have agreed on a joint declaration to
increase the global operation for
bettering energy security and
Independence namely through offshore
wind energy and here I'm glad that we
have a common ambition for offshore wind
capacity that will increase seven times
also wind will help us to produce more
affordable and clean energy and
decarbonize our gas systems thanks to
the hydrogen production what is also
very important is having better
connections with neighbors and a key
example is the ongoing project of
synchronization of Baltic electricity
grades to Europe where I'm very thankful
for the European support as well to
fulfill the offshore targets Estonia has
proposed also the Baltic offshore grade
initiative which aims to commonly plan
and develop necessary great
infrastructure in the Baltic Sea and we
also discussed this today I'm very glad
that Estonia is developing together with
Latvia
joined offshore wind farm and today we
heard from Ursula that it's also
included to be a European project so so
we are very proud to be part of this and
I'm also very glad that we are working
together be to be more interconnected by
increasing cross-border capacities and
links as well as working towards a
functioning common energy Market in our
region and all this is to have more
affordable Energy prices
Estonia is also planning to adopt an
integrated planning permit for offshore
wind to simplify development and also
today we discussed how we have to
proceed with the common planning
procedures for the projects that are
European we will announce in Estonia
several new new renewable energy Tenders
in coming years in order to have more
Investments to energy and of course
although uh becoming um sustainable has
is a long-term goal for all of us
Russia's invasion in Ukraine has
increased this speed of this process and
and we will stand for stopping the use
of Russian energy
as soon as possible by using more
renewable energy resources all together
and if we are not using Russian energy
we are not fueling the war in Ukraine
either and I also uh hope and express my
hope that we are able to cut All Imports
of Russia's energy to European Union for
good
we cannot simply use the energy
resources of an aggressor while Russia
is torturing killing people in Ukraine
by that I will conclude thank you thank
you so much and now The Apprentice of
Finland
their colleagues representatives of the
media I want to thank prime minister
Mata Fredrickson for inviting us to this
important event to discuss energy
Security in the Baltic Sea region our
discussion today shows that we can do a
lot together in strengthening the
security of Supply by increasing
renewable production and interconnectors
Russia's cruel war against Ukraine has
affected us all in many ways process is
using energy supplies as a tool as a
weapon to put pressure on our societies
Europe's depends the dependency on
Russian fossil fuels must come to an end
as soon as possible we are now moving
towards that goal Finland has already
cut out ties to Russia's gold coal and
oil the gas pipeline deliveries also
came to an end already months ago
our meeting today is important as we are
facing the current challenges together
in Europe and together we are we have
the possibility to embrace the change
the energy crisis shows that Europe
needs strategic autonomy also in energy
Supply we can't rely on authoritarian
States as partners in supplying goods
and energy that are crucial for the
security of our Nations and our citizens
by speeding up the green transition and
moving away from fossil fuels we can
combat climate change and also increase
our strategic autonomy the Baltic Sea
region countries can contribute to
energy Supply security both in our own
region and more widely in the European
Union to do that we need an increase in
the production of Renewables in all of
our countries and better in the
connections
in the current situation we need
solidarity and unity in Europe This is
crucial
finally I want to thank thank the
president of the European Commission
Ursula the commission's import has been
most valuable throughout the crisis and
I'm waiting for further contributions
when the European Council soon meets
again and discusses energy issues
Finland is ready to contribute
positively in order to find solutions
that will help Europe through the period
of sources of supply and Rising prices
in the upcoming months thank you thank
you so much and now the Prime Minister
of Latvia is
thank you very much thank you very much
Mata for inviting all of us greetings to
everyone
I think all of us know the stories from
the Bible from the Old Testament where
the father is explaining to his sons the
strength of a single twig that he gives
a twig to his son and he breaks it he
gives another one and he breaks it and
then he gives a whole bunch together and
they cannot break it and he says to his
sons
this is the way you must live if you try
to do it on your own you'll be broken
like The Twig but if you stick together
you cannot be broken and here we are
very symbolically standing together as
that bundle of sticks in the European
Union we have a very clear task in front
of us it's difficult but it can be done
Russia's brutal war in Ukraine is it
creates the imperative for us to
decouple our economies from Russia and
crucially to
stop our common
energy dependence on Russia this can be
done not on a one by one basis but when
we all work together
working together on interconnectors
working together on renewable energy
projects working together to get the
legislation the European and the
national legislation in place to get the
permitting process for these very needed
projects up and running and if we
continue to work together as we have so
far if we consider our support for
Ukraine providing weapons providing
finances providing humanitarian Aid it
came without question it came from all
of us the Same Spirit we need to
maintain and doing a task which will
take a little more time is maybe a
little more difficult but it is
decoupling our energy
dependence on Russia getting rid of this
energy dependence moving into Renewables
on joint projects this is what we talked
about today and this is what we will
solve together thank you very much thank
you Auntie Thomas president of Lithuania
thank you thank you dear Mata for
hosting this very important meeting and
I hope very much that it will be not
one-off event and we will have the
possibilities to continue our
discussions on a regular basis
Russia's war in Ukraine has become a
push for energy transformation in Europe
the rose tinted glasses have fallen off
many leaders in Europe have finally
realized that Russia is not a reliable
partner in any field especially in
energy using it as a tool of political
manipulation and blackmail
Russia has weaponized energy once again
the price of gas gas has increased 10
times electricity prices are breaking
records four Euros per one kilowatt hour
for lithium electricity consumers is now
the Justified nor bearable I call the
European institutions to act swiftly on
a price tackling measures on the
European Union level
Lithuania came to realize that moving
away from Russia's energy resources is
an absolute necessity much earlier
decades ago we took strategic decisions
that increased our energy Independence
thanks to LNG and World terminals
electricity grids to Sweden and Poland
lithinia was able to refuse the Imports
of Russian oil electricity and gas in
April 2022.
however this does not guarantee full
energy security the Baltic countries
still have to break away completely from
the Russian electricity grid we must
complete synchronization with the
Continental Europe
uh great I call for accelerating the
implementation of the Baltic
synchronization project I also thank
European commission and personally you
uh president founder lion for taking
very active role in this the future of
energy is to move away from fossil fuels
to Renewables when a photovoltaic green
hydrogen and flexible energy storage to
do that we need political will and
commitment lithin is determined to
follow the Green Path and is committed
to make a Swift together with the Baltic
Sea region the green deal is also our
deal
Europe is standing on the verge of the
energy transformation it is time to make
the Strategic decisions that will
determine the future of energy it might
be challenging no doubt I see it though
as a historical opportunity for the
European union to become energy secure
thank you thank you so much and the
prime minister of Poland matters thank
you thank you Mata for organizing this
very important Summit and this is you
know very important Summit in exactly
in in the context of the energy
transformation which is one of the most
critical tasks for all of us but I don't
want to repeat with everything which was
what was said I agree with all what my
predecessor said I I just wanted to make
a couple of comments linking or
connecting some dots on on this picture
what is today the symbol of
energy system
in the context of the Baltic Sea
these are probably for many people North
stream one and North stream two pipes
these are the two pipes which enabled
Putin to attack Ukraine
I'm absolutely certain that without
those two pipes he would not dare
attacking Ukraine because there would
not have been another rude route to
transfer his gas to Europe
many years before he dared to attack
Ukraine For the First Time 2014 and then
on the 24th of February this year
so the real prize for cheap gas cheap
energy some people would have hoped for
this is the blood of Ukraine
and this is the challenge of nowadays we
cannot talk about energy transformation
as a separate challenge energy
transformation should be a supplement
that should be corresponding compatible
with energy security there is no real
energy transformation without energy
security
Russia Today has wrapped a web of energy
dependence around some member states of
the European Union and this is a kind of
deadly web so
we need to collectively find solutions
to counteract those
um
those attacks because I I view the
Kremlin policy as
the attack on us on the European Union
and this is why this is a time to think
out of box
and
just two ideas in the mode of out of box
thinking one
affordable
ETS system why to add on very high
electricity prices another 90 or 100
euro in the form of ETS
allowances
we can revert back to the system
the moment we secure energy for all of
Europe and we bring back peace to
Ukraine and second idea is around
pricing mechanism
I I believe that Putin is now sitting
and laughing at us because some of the
mechanism pricing mechanisms which we
have created as the complex system in
Europe uh are dependent on us but we are
not changing them dependent on on the
European Union and we are not
um changing them whereas they are
enhancing the painful policy uh by uh
made by Putin made by Russia and by this
I mean changing
philosophy of the pricing mechanism
calculations around Merit order marginal
prices and uh they they all should
should be
um changed right now uh for the sake of
cheaper prices for our companies and our
citizens
we have to have reliable Partners this
is why this Summit is also so
interesting not only from the point of
view of security but also future
cooperation but long term is now in
contradict with short term long term we
I fully subscribe to all offshore Wind
Farm strategies Poland is also planning
huge Wind Farm Investments but right now
we need stable delivery of stable supply
of electricity affordable electricity
prices and and secure Energy System
and this is why I believe that we should
also think about all sorts of different
actions to push back Russia's effort to
destabilize us and this morning I spoke
to Gary Kasparov and Mikhail
kondorkovsky in Warsaw and we were of
the same view as many of us here
standing here that we should stop giving
visas to uh Russian citizens
um I I think that this is yet another
tool of putting pressure on the Kremlin
and this is an appropriate one so uh all
in all we are we all agree that
um huge transformation is ahead of us
but all should be viewed in the context
of this tragedy of war and atrocities
happening in Ukraine and this is why we
should focus on the short-term Solutions
uh which are not only bearable
affordable for our citizens and our
companies but also country do contribute
uh for the
um for the win for the victory of
Ukraine which I hope will happen in not
so distant future thank you thank you
Mrs and then finally president of the
commissioners
foreign
it's wonderful to be here with you the
leaders and I think the Baltic Sea
leaders Summit shows that a Wind of
Change is blowing across Europe
we are harnessing the power of wind to
break free from Russian fossil fuels and
to become climate neutral and offshore
wind energy can make a huge contribution
to that
with the targets that have been set
today
Baltic Sea offshore wind will cover the
energy consumption of around 6 million
households by 2030. that is more than
the number of households in Denmark
Lithuania Latvia and Estonia combined
that's amazing and we can do so much
more
we now need Regional cooperation to
realize the full potential of offshore
wind in Europe
so the European commission strongly
supports the regional Corporation
initiatives such as this one
we're making available
5.6 billion euros from Next Generation
EU for the deployment of offshore and
onshore wind in Europe so I encourage
member states to work together and using
these funds the cross-border project are
so important
we want to prioritize hybrid projects
which link offshore wind farms with more
than one member state
because hybrid projects will save space
that would save money they can cut up to
10 percent of project costs and indeed a
great example the akaya is the Elven
offshore wind project
and I'm very glad that today we could
select elwind as an important
cross-border project PCI because it
makes it eligible for EO funding under
the connectivity Europe facility and
that is good news
one more important point is we will
accelerate the permitting process we
know it's far too long many many years
six to nine years
in the repower EU plan there is a
proposals to speed up this permitting
process so I encourage member states to
endorse the proposal and implement it
then we could guarantee that the
permitting process is less than one year
now I think it is important indeed that
we look at the different topics that
bring us to the electricity price
situation we are right in now
and dear prime minister
moravesh I'm with you in one point I'm
not so much with you in another point if
I may mention that first we need the
mission trading system to cut CO2
emissions because it is the CO2 that
causes climate change and we know how
much the impact the negative impact the
devastating impact of climate change is
already threatening us we just have to
look at the droughts this summer
but the real driver for the increase of
electricity prices
is somewhere else that is gas
and mainly Russian gas that has been
manipulated by Putin
Putin who uses gas as a weapon
and you can see that in the figures
if you look at the electricity price
94 of the electricity price is composed
of other things mainly gas
than ETS is only six percent
or if you look at the evolution of the
price compared to last year
ETS increased by 58 mainly because more
coal is used
but gas increased by
580 percent tenfold
so we should really address the driver
of this electricity price increase
that's what we need to tackle and I
think climate policy is security policy
because if we invest in Renewables they
are homegrown they are clean they are
cheaper and they make us independent we
are absolutely with you prime minister
moravetski de amateurs is the pricing
mechanisms of the electricity market and
you know that I've announced yesterday
that we're looking into it to develop an
emergency tool and to work for long-term
structural reform of the electricity
Market this has to be addressed the
electricity Market is not no more a
functioning Market because there is one
actor Putin who is systematically trying
to destroy it
and to manipulate it so we really have
to react to that and that's why we're
addressing now the composition of the
electricity market and there I'm with
you matthiosh last but not least
Putin's attempt to Blackmail us with
fossil fuels is failing we are
accelerating the green transition we are
getting rid of the dependency of Russian
fossil fuels and we're accelerating the
renewable clean cheaper and homegrown
renewable energy thank you
thank you
he has the taken government will now say
questions the first question is for
Danish broadcaster TV so Greg hemingsen
how long is a short-term solution is the
short and a question for you guys I
heard you say as soon as possible
and I heard you say this is a a big step
towards a green solution to the energy
energy crisis as well but I think many
people in the Baltic Sea region would
like to know how will this help us the
fact that you guys are standing here
right now how will this help us get
through this winter the prices are
really high already people are already
struggling out there how is the short
term solution short
well if I may start Finland has already
decoupled from Russian fossil fuels
because we have invest in Renewables
over decades so we have been four-sided
when it comes to this situation and now
we have to make sure that we are
cooperating and that we are working
together that we have the solidarity uh
among European countries and we need
Solutions many kind of solutions of
course commission has proposed many
solutions and I think all of these are
very good ones and we are also
discussing more in upcoming European
councils I think the main issue is not
only the production of energy not only
the interconnections but also the prices
and I think there's much more that we
can do when it comes to the prices we
are very open to discuss everything from
Price caps to tolls to to different
measures that we could use the lowering
down the prices because it's also to do
with the war the support that we need
from the European citizens to help
Ukraine to make sure that Ukraine will
win the war so we have to make sure that
we are taking seriously the citizens
situation now with the high energy
prices
the second question is from set deaf
jorgenheiman
I have a question to Mrs Collins maybe
your
colleagues from the Baltic countries
um
now have you chosen an island
as Bonhomme for a great connection
between your countries as
we have been between Denmark Germany and
Sweden and Future
I know you have a lot of islands there
up there and more more
severe question
short-term uh what importance does
finland's future NATO membership have
for your countries
when Finland and Sweden are joining then
the center of gravity of NATO moves
North and and I think we can all be more
secure because then the Baltic Sea will
be more secure as well and today's topic
has been the offshore wind energy and we
are talking about the energy grid so
that we are all connected to each other
but we are also able to defend what we
have also to defend the energy grade but
also the offshore so that we can we can
function so I think this is only a
positive side that Finland and Sweden
are joining thank you
thank you we are a bit depressed for
time so so short questions please this
time from Finnish broadcaster Carolina
Cantona
uh Norway has expressed its intention to
limit its export of energy so does this
declaration and show that other
countries won't set any limitations to
their export
thank you
I think we have a
single asset that is very valuable and
this is the integrated
um electricity Market in the European
Union because every member State
experiences that at a certain time it is
exporting but at a certain time it is
importing and only because we have this
integrated uh European energy Market
electricity Market are we able to
prevent uh blackouts
um Christianity's current was with his
example of this uh Twigs
showing that if you're alone then you
are pretty much in a problem the moment
one of the energy sources sources is
getting short but if you had 27 you can
always compensate and that what we see
on a daily basis
and then the final question news polish
prime minister have mentioned the need
to implement
Visa ban for Russian citizens but you
European countries are split on this
issue how can we convince countries like
France Germany touristic hubs like
Greece Cyprus and is there any
compromise possible one solution for all
the European Union or if not compromise
then what else
I I would like to remind to remind you
the example of candidate status to
Ukraine I remember the time as many
colleagues were very critically uh
negative about possibility to Grant the
candidate's status to Ukraine but it
took about several months and the
situation changed and the opinion the
mindset has changed I hope that we will
have wonderful opportunities to meet
each other in European Council
and to discuss this issue because I
think this is not fear to see this
bloody war in Ukraine leaving letting
people die civil people die in
destructed infrastructure and at the
same time the Russian tourists here in
the courage of Europe This is not
acceptable and of course especially not
acceptable looking with the eyes of the
Baltic countries and Scandinavian
countries
thank you very much that wraps up this
part of the press conference in 10
minutes time there'll be an opportunity
for press pools for those of you that
have made such Arrangements they will be
in front of marinboro then subsequently
at six o'clock we'll be resuming the
press conference with the press
conference of energy ministers where
there will be a signing ceremony of the
energy ministers declaration and further
declaration strengthening cooperation
amongst the countries in the Baltic Sea
thank you